there was one thing on everyone's mind
that the 2023 Oscars and the host for
the evening Jimmy Kimmel handled it
exactly how you'd expect you remember
the slap everyone does so we probably
don't need to explain it again but we're
gonna do that anyway last year when
Chris Rock made a comment about Jada
Pinkett Smith's lack of hair while
presenting an award calling her GI Jane
Smith exploded yelling keep my wife's
name out your mouth yelled this
repeatedly after storming on stage and
smacking Chris Rock the moment
immediately became one of the most
infamous shots in Oscar history and
Smith a newly minted winner for his work
in King Richard was banned from future
ceremonies in the weeks have followed
there was endless exhausting and
constant debate about who was in the
wrong and it remains one of the weirdest
and most unexpected moments in the
history of the ceremony one thing is for
certain though it will remain a part of
Smith's narrative for the rest of his
career Rock for his part recently
addressed the slap in his first stand-up
special since the encounter
what happened to me getting smacked by
Suge Smith
meanwhile Smith has repeatedly
apologized for the incident but what
about this year's Oscars everyone
wondered how it would be addressed in
the days leading up to the awards show
fortunately this massive elephant in the
room got her dressed quickly and swiftly
thanks to host Jimmy Kimmel when Will
Smith slapped Chris Rock across the face
for insulting his wife Jada Pinkett
Smith it was a smack heard around the
world so naturally audiences were doomed
to hear jokes about it during this
year's ceremony before noting how many
Irish actors were nominated this year
which could lead to a fight breaking out
on the stage Kimmel got direct Kimmel
confirmed that there is a crisis team in
place in case of any violence this year
and pointed out some of his enforcers in
the audience including Pedro Pascal and
the Fable man himself Steven Spielberg
he also encouraged the audience to do
what they did last year to help nothing
there's an incentive if you do slap
someone apparently though Kimmel said if
anyone in this theater commits an act of
violence at any point during the show he
will be awarded the Oscar for best actor
and permitted to give a 19 minute long
speed each Cameo was clearly referencing
how Smith post slap wept strong and
emotional acceptance speech for best
actor for various reasons Will Smith not
surprisingly was not in attendance at
this year's Oscars Kimmel's jokes didn't
stop after his monologue though a 40
Award for best documentary was given
else which was when the slab famously
happened last year Kimmel said hopefully
this time it goes without a hitch or
without a hitch please put your hands
together or keep them to yourself Quest
love who won the documentary feature
Oscar last year for summer of Seoul was
on hand to present which is a nice touch
as his victory and first Oscar win was
completely overshadowed by the fracas
that followed around the two hour mark
of the show because the Oscars are
whether they feature any Infamous laps
or not famously long Kimmel quipped this
point in the show kind of makes you miss
her slapping a little right it's a bit
bold on Kimmel's part to say that the
Oscars are so boring that somebody needs
to smack somebody else in the face for
them to be interesting yeah probably but
if Kimmel doesn't keep referencing the
biggest Oscars moments since the La La
Land and Moonlight mix-up people might
change the channel and go check out the
finale of The Last of Us instead
foreign
[Music]